dans quel jeu télé pouvait-on toucher le
pactole
après avoir gratté les 3t les
[Musique]
jeunes un pactole les trois télés le
bigdil
c'est pas et si on vous dit que la
prochaine escale de notre road trip est
au mexique ça vous rassure mais le
mexique
pour de raphia mexique et en amérique
latine moi si je reste
ce n'est pas parce que les mexicains
emploie des termes comme olé muchacho
qu'il crèche forcément à côté de
l'espagne faut arrêter un peu hâlé
réseau
[Musique]
elle mange quatre tablettes de chocolat
en une semaine en 21 jours alors on a
mangé combien
les 21 jours c'est combien ces trois
semaines et ben voilà et bien donc trois
fois quatre ça fait combien
on va la terre au même moment où vous
êtes précipité sur une jeune demoiselle
cruellement d aller au lit d'ailleurs
c'est quoi ton prénom mais ça suffit
c'est pas possible mais c'est pas
possible non mais non
mais non il s'est jeté sur les autels
moi ton corps là il lui dit c'est quoi
ton prénom et on se rappelle lé fais ok
d'accord à l'achat sur lapin est ouverte
mais ça va pas
du moment tu te vois genre plus tard
dans 10 ans
cherche me va marier je me vois pas plus
que des enfants ouais mais sont faits
dans un patrimoine magnifique je pense
il parle dans
les autres ont déjà un mais 80 mais 98 -
de comment ça c'est sûr il serait
triperie bono en vain le midi mais que
ça sera pas possible bebela votre petite
pucelle et tête en bas attendons donc ça
c'est super du coup pour l'accouchement
par voie basse qu'elle soit attendant
pourquoi mais c'est vrai dans une
position assez bas normands la tête en
bas bah oui mais autant il ya des bébés
qui sont donc qui présente le siège d'en
bas enfin tout dépend en fait de
commencer à la nature donc quand on est
quand on
marche la tête en l'air si on s'en va on
est mineur aulas au lieu de vous presser
la salle du moulin
[Musique]
anzhi bac s il ya un bébé auquel est
mignon et une basse et les lycées mois
[Musique]
c'est un mauvais garçon mais non
mais voilà c'est moi les gars ont
enchaîné dans le mauvais
non et je verrai ce soir oui alors j'ai
dit ce rouleur parce que j'ai tout de
suite compter les étoiles
j'ai compté les lettres et je vous ai
dit le seul rookie of the who après
trois ans d'absence le festival de
musique coachella a fait son grand
retour ce week end dans le désert
californien sur youtube aussi l'on
pouvait visionner en direct les concerts
en chine c'est sur l'application ou chat
qu'a eu lieu la retransmission avec une
particularité de la censure en live un
rectangle noir totalement dépassés lors
du spectacle de la rappeuse mégane
l'espagnol
finit j'étais garçon maintenant chez une
femme
après jeter les bases de la seconde à
l'esprit je suis je suis bouleversée je
tombe des nues je commence à avoir chaud
je commence à me sentir pas bien ça
c'est un secret de ouf on fait après
valencia n'est pas 10 parce que je
tenais vraiment le à te le dire en face
tu va accueillir ont joué que le 12 le
mot de trop
démesuré très bien les retraités de quoi
marc barr traité de dédoubler bien haut
il ya une usine là bas c'est ça
absolument oui à evian les bains et
qu'est ce que vous faisiez vous
marier dans la logistique au niveau
international arrivé à celle qu'on
connaît bien on connaît bien mais carey
prochaine oui parce que c'est ce qu'on
veut en général quand on voit ricard
mais
modération
jamais goûté c'est bon
[Musique]
moment saint brès avec michael
franchement c
je me dis waouh genre 6 et émouvant